hi guys and welcome to this week's
episode as you know we're partnered with
cutie which is a social media company
that tries to create a space for
interesting insightful conversations
like the ones that we have here so head
over to the link in the pinned comment
and in the description to get your
chance to say what you think and we're
doing things a little bit differently
this week we are going to be talking
about the coronavirus on this week's
cutie because the world is [ __ ]
ending and why not yeah let's have a
chat about how we're all about to die so
head over to the link in the pinned
comment and we'll see you there the top
5 answers will get pinned and discussed
in next week's stream hello welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster
I'm constant in kitten and this is a
show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our guest this week unsurprisingly is a
medical expert he's a global health
researcher and an epidemiologist a word
that I find impossible to say dr.
Michael head welcome to trigonometry
thank you thank you for having me on
thank you for coming to my home thanks
for letting us in there to spread our
corona if we have it but you could EMU
ologists I managed to say it it's the
profession has become a lot of sexier
these days doesn't it yes no one had
heard of us until about 2 or 3 months
ago and then suddenly we're in the news
everywhere so our sexiness rating has
gone from zero to well maybe a little
bit but it is there now tell us what an
epidemiologist is first of all because I
assumed it was someone who studies
epidemics but actually it's just someone
who studies disease yeah so the word
epidemiology epidemiology hard to say
literally means the study of disease so
you do have epidemiologists who study
non-infectious disease stuff so there's
epidemiology you do cancer and heart
disease and stroke and all that sort of
thing and then as those of us like me
who do infectious diseases and suddenly
we are sexy oh wow so you've become a
celebrity now
yes I mean in the last couple of months
coronavirus has kicked off big time and
really in the past have I been in demand
like this had done the occasional bit in
the media in the past but when my press
office first asked me about this
outbreak as kicking off in shell
they said if the press come along do you
want to comment I said yeah behind no
worries and then the press did come
along and actually asked me to comment I
thought well hang on let's get googly
now I guess he had a knife because no
one knew anything about him the people
are asking us questions that we didn't
know the answers to so I think it
certainly initially are kind of
collective responses to the media was
basically don't know really let's try
and find out things as we go along and
but so yes we've been in a large amount
of demand of a lot a couple of months
all right well let's get into the reason
why obviously this situation is good it
has come to the fore and in a way that
people didn't many people didn't expect
myself included Francis has been banging
on about it for months now I've been
banging on about it and in Constantine's
words don't worry about it it's just a
bit of I readily admit but what I
started to notice is all the people that
I follow and Twitter scientists that
we've had on the show in the past all of
them were taken as seriously and it was
[ __ ] like me going always just the
flu so on balance I thought maybe this
is serious
and obviously now it really is we're
recording this on Thursday you probably
go out in a few days from now things
that seem to be picking up so one of the
things I wanted to start with is how
serious is it now and how serious is it
likely to get so where are we at the
moment so it is proper serious often you
see people up there being a bit more
pragmatic so saying well isn't it's not
serious yet that's other thing we are at
the stage where globally and the UK it
is serious it's bad and it is quite
scary and we now have at least two
hundred thousand diagnosed cases around
the world there'll be many many more
times than that undiagnosed focusing on
the UK we are you've seen all the graphs
with the various peaks on them that are
constantly in there in the news we are
basically at the start of that peak or
so you have to start at that graph and
the bottom end of it the peak is yet to
come that will be over the coming weeks
or months and then hopefully in a few
months time at least the numbers will
subside if not the problem but to even
to get to the point where we've reached
the top and start to come down again
that's still a long way off so there's a
lot of pain yet to come so we're at the
very very beginning of this do you think
that the government were reckless in
their pursuit of herd immunity and
saying well the majora
people will get it and then they will
create essentially a group of people who
are immune to it and then we can carry
on as a society I think that was
slightly poorly explained um but there's
a theory behind it and the theory works
whether the practice doesn't know is
another matter that when you get an
infection after most infections you do
have a bit of immunity left to it so if
you have the flu you don't normally get
that strain of flu again quickly if at
all if you get the common cold you
almost never get that strain again
there's lots of different types of
common cold which is why we always get
colds um so the theory here and there's
a little bit of evidence to back up but
we don't really know properly yet is
that people will have some level
immunity we don't know how long for so
if enough people do get it we don't want
that to happen clearly because that's a
problem but if enough people do get it
then that might have some protective
effect upon those who haven't got it yet
but we don't know the answer to that and
what we do need is a test which is
coming in probably a few weeks but not
yet that will tell us if people have had
the disease so the tests at the moment
are testing for the kind of the virus as
you got it your tests for there for RNA
which is a bit like DNA but their
genetic code basically so we can test
accurately for that whether you've
already had it you need to test for
antibodies essentially so there is
diagnostic firms in the UK and around
the world like us or frantically racing
each other to produce some really good
quality tests to look at the people who
have already had the disease and then
that can inform us all of our strategies
going forward if we know that everyone's
had it you can then send them back to
work for example and things like that so
it would be a bit of a game changer if
if and as someone we do have it and we
will have at some point but that's a few
weeks away and a few weeks in a pandemic
is a very very long time indeed yeah
well actually this is one of the things
that I one of the reasons I wanted to
get into how serious it is because you
know my wife went into town to do some
shopping yesterday and she was saying I
don't think people are getting the
message coz particularly older people
they're still out and about they think
like a comedian friend of us posted
saying they think it's a bank holiday
for old people the thing that's
happening I don't think people are
taking it seriously but going off the
government's figures if they're
estimating up to 80 percent of the
public are going to get this disease
and 1% in which is seems to be pre
reasonable estimate will die from it
well if you do the math there's like
half a million people minimum half a
million people will die from this and a
lot of people you know we saw these
videos from you know English fans
football fans or whatever in Tenerife or
whatever you know it's just a bit flew
mate just let me know
legends base I'm not even sure they were
football fans it just looked like
football fans anyway so my point is
there are people can not take in as
seriously when when we talk about it
being serious how many people are gonna
die from this well we don't know I think
we can probably safely say it's going to
be thousands maybe tens of thousands
that half a million figure and the 80%
figure and that's the kind of upper
level estimates that's the worst case
scenario so when we get modelers to
calculate to kind of try to predict the
future which is subsidies so uncertain
what's on that list they do have to
calculate basically kind of the worst
level scenarios so that people can plan
for that scenario if you put measures in
place like all this social distancing
and shutting things down
we should not get anywhere near that
worst-case scenario but it is still a
possibility there's just no guarantees
people often say right how many people
gonna die how bad is it going to be
don't know it's a short answer but I
don't think we will gets that 80% and a
half a million people dying but was it
still will be plenty of excess deaths
not good and who are the people most at
risk of this is it particularly elderly
is it the people who for instance having
cancer treatments chemotherapy and there
were particular set of people who are at
risk I mean it is the most vulnerable
people in society which includes the
elderly so the kind of the rough cut off
is 70 or above and the older you get the
bigger the risks are I think if you're
over 90 the death rate for about 20 or
25% it's pretty big if you're between 70
and 90 again it kind of goes up from 70
to 80 and Beyond but it's many percent
of people will die in a particular
demographic in terms of children and
young adults the death rate is actually
pretty low there's still are some
complications people are still being
emitted the hospital children and so on
but overwhelming big burden of disease
the serious burden of disease isn't
elderly it's in people like say who are
having cancer treatments and people with
cystic fibrosis and if you've got other
comorbidities as we call it they say
they've got other things already wrong
with you like hypertension and diabetes
if you've had a stroke to a certain
extent respiratory conditions like
asthma or chronic obstructive pulmonary
disorder COPD they're all risk factors
that increase the chances of if you get
coated and if you get the crown of us
then you are lucky a bit more ill than
people who are younger and haven't got
comorbidities what about lifestyle stuff
like being overweight smoking you know
hot stuff like that yeah so smoking is
certainly linked to increased risk of
being hospitalized that's the kind of
often metric we use as to how serious it
is do we need to go to hospital that's
the kind of kind of benchmark for a
serious case often definition very
little baby you can kind of use that as
a benchmark so you're more likely to be
hospitalized if you're a smoker I mean
if you are obese enough like you're more
than to have things like diabetes and so
on so that would then contribute to a
risk factor that would elevate the
likelihood of seriousness in your
particular case it's all risk factors it
doesn't mean it's going to happen but it
increases the chances of a worse case
and I saw like I'm going to use a lot of
this interview to explode some myths
because as we as we're all on social
media we've seen a lot of people saying
certain things and you know people
getting quite worried about it they they
were saying there is a link between
anti-inflammatories and exacerbating the
condition is this true is this not true
or do we simply not know don't just for
people who may not know
anti-inflammatories been things like
ibuprofen it's alright so that probably
is through that one we don't know so the
link first came from I think that the
French Health Minister who first stated
it and then a few doctors have given a
fuse or pragmatic viewpoints that this
probably is the case that paracetamol is
a better painkiller I think that the
latest guidance as I say this right now
is that if you are have been told by
your doctor to take the things that
ibuprofen then carry on doing so but
maybe have a word with them just to see
what
later skouries and if you do have
symptoms of the corona virus and try and
take paracetamol rather than ibuprofen
I'm on quite strong ibuprofen that's
myself in the menu got slightly dodgy
hip some on these anti-inflammatories so
I'm watching that one with great
interest
mmm and it's interesting you you said
that and also as well I really want to
focus on this because I find it deeply
worrying you know people just going oh
I'm just living my life normally blah
blah blah like for instance if I'm young
I'll be fine
what effect does that actually have and
are you putting people at serious risk
if you essentially go and live your life
like you were like you used to last
month for three weeks ago and you are
putting people at risk because you might
be fine but that therein is not the
problem here the population at large and
if you want to personalize it your
elderly relatives might not be fine so
if you live your life as normal and
mix-a-lot and having lots of contact
with other people and if you then take a
corona virus into your grandmother's
house for example then there might be
problems afoot
because that's a vulnerable person
you're affecting right there so we do
all have a big responsibility to
actually just behave a little bit and
follow the public health guidance the
kind of measures have been put in place
to reduce the amount that we mix with
each other and large gatherings and
things like that there is a point to it
and it is to kind of reduce those big
peaks and just to make the whole country
a bit more a slightly easier place to
live in and we all have a responsibility
to contribute to that so there you go
trigonometry we're being irresponsible
by having this face to face so you don't
have to and also I don't get to see my
mother hey thank you for that I sure
would say I think the current guidance
suggests that gatherings of more than 10
are ill-advised and there's currently
three of us in front camera if there's
something behind the camera four we're
fine we're fine
we don't have symptoms together I think
anybody know I actually have a feeling I
might have had it already cuz like three
or four weeks ago I had a dry cough and
a bit of a fever I mean that could
easily have been the corona of ice again
in many people Simon
you you may be superhuman no in a very
precise way
thank you very much up no it's like to
say like only the good die young anyway
um so then uh that's a point so for
instance in February the 14th I remember
it because it was Valentine's weekend
and my girlfriend was very angry but I
had I developed a fever and a cough how
likely is it that people have already
had this in like last month in February
always did it only really appear in
March and so on I mean it was around in
frippery there were far fewer cases so
it's actually less likely mmm there you
have had corona virus the thing is
January February season Northern
Hemisphere there's flu and coughs and
colds everywhere so that's also been a
bit of a problem because hospitals and
doctors surgeries are handling flu cases
and slightly more and other a spirit
infections as well along with this brand
new thing that's been thrown into the
mix one of the reasons why it's better
to try to deal with these things over
the summer is that as fewer
things like that's out the fewer cases
the flu out there so if people are
getting these symptoms now from now on
it's more likely to be corona virus
because there's less flu around so that
makes the kind of diagnosis and case
management that bit easier than it has
been across the winter and the question
are another question who really want
clarified is if somebody who is young
fit and healthy gets it what are they
likely to experience in terms of
symptoms and what impact is it likely to
have on them because again people have
been sharing all sorts of nonsense
articles on Facebook and Twitter and so
on I mean most people I mean roughly 80%
that people who get it are not fine but
it's very lower-level symptoms it's it's
the equivalent you feel about as grotty
as you do when you get a normal cold for
example but obviously the key as has
been emphasized repeatedly by the chief
medical officer is his kind it's not
about you as a relatively young healthy
person who's kind of all right it's
about protecting the people around you
who are potentially not going to be
right forget it and it's also about
protecting the health system from and a
large swamp in off cases what you know
who needs access to ICU beds or
ventilators whatever don't there's not
enough of those things to go around if
everyone gets the disease at the same
time yeah so I mean if there's gonna be
a lot of people with a fever on the
coffin the minutes as we go forth to be
even more they need to hang around at
home and self isolate so that the health
facilities GPS our hospitals are freer
than the otherwise would have been so
they can concentrate on the
proper serious stuff and you were saying
that we're at the start of the process
what does that mean can you guide us
through what you think the government
are going to do and the modelers are
going to advise a government to do well
I think we probably got a clear strategy
in place for the next few weeks which
will be schools closed to kind of keep
your distance from everyone so protect
the elderly so there's kind of fewer
visits degrading that sort of thing
the kind of advice is out there as I
speak right now is probably the sort of
advice we're gonna have with us for at
least a few weeks I suspect that we'll
probably probably look at that again I
mean we looked at again all the time but
then we might see significant changes
maybe around May or so as we start to
hit the peak yeah hopefully by then
we'll be someone near the peak and
things like we might see for example
schools opening up again for a short
period of time because closing schools
it's a big step yeah it's got a such an
impact upon everyone else it has the
potential to take frontline health
workers out the way it means parents
can't go to work and can't earn money so
there's all these kind of secondary
consequences from the relatively simple
act of closing schools but it then gets
complicated and that's what we to some
extent need to live our lives at least a
little bit and also compliance with
these public health guidelines we've
talked a little bit about lack of
compliance that we've seen it is likely
very likely the compliance will get less
as we go through as people get a little
bit fed up with it
and get a bit of if you're scusa phrase
cabin fever from being at home the whole
time so I think it's been mentioned that
well might have this course so-called
switching on and off of these big
interventions so we might switch off
school closures and open them up again
for a bit few weeks maybe so we might
have known if parents are basically I
mean I have two kids myself so I'll be
delighted with schools I think coming in
but say for example I've no idea if this
will happen but a guess on my part might
be that around the main half turn with
that kind of second half of that term
you might see the schools open up until
July and then you've got the six-week
summer holiday break there's kind of a
natural time when schools are closed
anyway so that sort of switching on and
off that's the sort of thing we might
see going forward so you don't think
that actually things are going to get to
stricter and harsher in the weeks to
come we're not gonna you don't expect
a lockdown where everyone just has to
stay at home and you get to go out for
an hour a day to walk the dog and buy
some food I mean that might happen
my sense is it won't but it does depend
a little bit on whether again whether
the population are flying at the moment
in the UK we kind of done this guidance
for the public rather than in other
scenarios some of the countries where it
has been looked at you are staying at
home like we seen for example in China
and some other countries they're big on
human rights I mean is quite big Lee
telling a population what to do yeah so
I think on the whole the slightly more
if you want to call it softly approach
of guiding people rather than telling
people is certainly in the short-term
better so actually I do hope we don't
need to have these kind of legally
enforced lockdowns
happen we shall see so from what you're
saying basically what I'm hearing is
this is gonna be with us until autumn at
the very least raise a fair to say I
think it's fair to say yeah and what
about the second peak idea where
essentially what like were the Spanish
flu there was the first peak and then
actually there was a lull and then it
came back do you think we may see that
with this as it early to tell was too
early to tell but we might do so we flew
most seasons actually even with seasonal
flu you normally get Peaks that's very
according to in the case of flu
according to wind the schools shut first
school holidays and so on so when the
shot have a Christmas a couple of weeks
flu cases drop because normally children
they're spreading it on the whole and as
a former teacher I hardly can go with
Constantine the only time has happened
in our show sorry carry on there was my
wife is a teacher if she was here she
may well contribute to this particular
yeah so we flew the often they are the
key transmitters and with coronavirus
although children do seem to be getting
it they don't they're not obviously the
kind of the the center of it they're not
the kind of conduits that really spread
but we do see those Peaks though in flu
seasons anyway and like you say the
Spanish flu there was clear things with
corona virus could easily see a peak we
might find the peak that's coming in a
few weeks if
we can get out on the other side of that
and have much lower cases the problem
might then come in the winter when
everything's about flus back common
colder back and coronavirus might
increase as well so we might have to see
a fair amount of again switching all of
those intervention and switching on the
social distancing and so on in the
winter um it's a trickier time to live
in the winter and particularly for the
vulnerable people even more so at that
point so comedians there's no comedy
shows anymore no right now so we are
vulnerable just through the hunger that
we experience but to be fair I need to
lose weight
absolutely but so this is going to be
with us for quite some time
and in terms of this the potential for
it to make a comeback on an immune level
are we going to be better prepared for
it coming back to be confirmed again we
don't know yeah if this herd immunity
theory takes hold might not be too bad
if a vaccine box up in 12 months will it
don't know there's lots lots of vaccine
candidates being looked at but because
we are pretty much starting from the
beginning there's been a bit of research
looking at other coronaviruses down the
years now the common cold one of the
causes of that is a corona virus
yeah yeah there's several different up
to corona virus some which are seen in
animals and not not so far being seen by
humans the common cold is the corona
virus you've heard of SARS of course
from years back MERS Middle Eastern
respiratory syndrome or camels right
camels exactly yeah bit right anyway you
know when someone offered me a hundred
and thirty camels for my wife
camels me you'd be richer and happier
anyway with the camels ah yes there's
not Stephen Crane a virus which the
common cold is one of the causes one of
the main causes coming I just like the
word it's the Rhino virus oh really yeah
yeah um so the great advice cause of the
common cold I've actually lost a point
to what the question originally question
was are we gonna get a vaccine anytime
so yeah so there has been lots of
research on the common cold
including vaccine stuff fairly recently
and back in the day
and with sirs sorry SARS and MERS and
his coronavirus identity there's been a
bit of laboratory stuff going on to kind
of prod and poke the virus and look at
the immune response in it in a
laboratory setting and we've but it's
not really got anywhere and it's not
really been a focus and actually I would
argue going forward and it should have
been already that Loras is with pandemic
potential I mean new we've had warning
shots with SARS things like that that
Kareena versus potentially that we
should have done tons more in the what
we call inter pandemic period between
scary times with research and
development looking at things like
vaccines and therapeutics and
diagnostics and all those other sorts of
things and but we haven't done so we've
been playing catch-up so with Ebola when
that was big outbreak in West Africa a
lot of works been done seats but and one
of the other things I do actually for
research is looking at how research
money is spent so because big global
database of how about 100 billion
dollars of research money has been spent
around the world in the last 20 years on
infectious diseases and we've looked at
things like corona barsen Ebola and flu
and if you want to look at mad cow
disease remember that from years back
but that's not a virus that's a prion
this is a prion as a protein very good
knowledge there might be arrest give you
a gold star but funding follows yeah the
kind of public health emergencies all
the public health concerns rather than
being in advance and there's something
been very bad out in the global
community is looking at problems in
advance doing a bit of kind of
forecasting and trying to work things
out more so we've started to get a bit
better but we've seen here that we're
know any good enough so I still have an
answer the question
Karina Vost vaccines the first phase one
trial that's the first time you chuck it
back to the into a human being to see
what happens to it that's just started
in America over the next few weeks we'll
probably see a few more vaccine
candidates child in a similar fashion
but we are way behind the curves that be
minimum than 12 months
I reckon before we have even a
half-decent vaccine the first vaccine
you see you're often not necessarily the
best ones this is a process of
refinement
I'm a choice is a refinement so it might
help that there's lots and lots of
competing vaccines and who will
hopefully all share data so you can kind
of just
process all information a bit more
real-time you would normally that will
be exceptionally lucky and fortunate to
have a cracking vaccine 12 months time I
suspect it probably be longer than that
ie vaccine might be better nothing but
it might not be the kind of Holy Grail
that cures everything it might give you
cancer thanks Michael what is a chance
that this could mutate into an even more
serious strain which proves even more
deadly for us the viruses mutate all the
time anyway and they very rarely mutates
into a more serious strain and Jim
really speak and what you see actually
is when a virus hanging around in the
human long enough it kind of adapts to
its host it's not good for the virus if
it kills everyone that sees instantly
because then it can't be spread this to
change stops so something like flu it's
quite good it doesn't kill that many
people but if it kind of is easy to
spread measles as well that's the kind
of most successful kind of virus there's
one that makes you ill enough to spread
it but doesn't kind of knock you out
altogether so mutation and viruses don't
necessarily mean bad they mutate all
time anyway
most mutations I mean nothing and almost
it seriously you could get worse and
meet more difficult to treat or so on
actually it's more likely to get
slightly more mild if anything but we
don't know what will happen about that's
all to be confirm it's such a new virus
it's only jumped into human three months
ago
whereas measles are flu we've had for
you know hundreds of thousands of years
so we know a bit more about how they
evolve and so on
but you can expect probably the 'quran
of us to behave in a similar fashion and
what what do you say to those people go
this is a man-made virus it was made in
the laboratories of Wuhan how convenient
they have this massive laboratory and
all of a sudden it started there and
it's the the Chinese are using it to
dominate the world
see there was a paper published as I
speak just yesterday he I think it was
in nature one of those are the big
scientific journals that pointed out
that this is dadgum gonna swear Ashley
this is bollocks this kind of man-made
theory and they pretty much they don't
use that swear though but they couldn't
say exactly that basically did
conspiracy theorists stop it so they can
show the sort of genetic lineage of it
and exactly how it
it's evolved and said it's not a manic
virus it's probably come from almost
only come from bats as the first
originator that's host viruses so well
and they don't have symptoms many of our
sort of potential future threats are
hanging around bats right now there was
probably in tonight God be careful this
could initiate a whole swathe of racist
attacks against bats yeah I think I
think people worm I think I can say
people just steer clear at bats
including eating lap which has been the
problem in China that bats are on the
menu and in these weirdly kind of big
markets with you seem to sort of that
the minis and Chinese have everything
they've got on the menu and people are
translated end there's pangolins there's
kind of cute little animals that's on
the menu there and they basically check
all these animals in a there's market
together and then they and then they eat
them also the kind of the potential for
transfer of genetic material of viruses
on between the animals and then the
humans are eating it all see humans are
preparing us they kind of slaughtering
in get common blood this on so that's
probably where the virus started in bats
probably by an intermediate house and a
Pangolin is one of the theories we don't
quite know that yet but this paper kind
of refutes the man-made theory and also
that point about there's a lab in Wuhan
that's the only level 4 lab in China
level fours the kind of higher level of
pathogen the boater and things like that
I said there's kind of level 1 to 4 so
comic holder for one about his own
before everything else is in the middle
I don't if it's still the only one any
level for one in China but there is one
in mu Han the way that's conspiracy
theory falls down in my view is that
curry Norris is not a level 4 pathogen
it's in level 2 labs on level 3 labs at
best so the level 4 thing is completely
irrelevant so you don't need level 4
level 4 lab to deal with it or research
it so again I'm going to use this way
but again it's bollocks but but also I
mean I have regular viewers of find this
funny but a relative of mine used to
work on the Soviet bioweapons program
because I'm from Russia originally okay
and I spoke to him edging slowly away
did have to drive past Salisbury again
who about great memories yes that's fine
still looking good but he was saying low
if you were developing a biological
weapon this is like the worst biological
weapon in history because what you want
with a biological weapon is you want to
kill healthy young men hmm who are the
enemy army and you want to do it quickly
you don't want to have a week-long
incubation period when they don't even
have any symptoms and you want to have a
lethality rate over 1% of a significant
level 1 percent so you certainly wasn't
you did you know the idea that it's
designed as a biological virus was made
in China and breaks down after sue yeah
so die I do agree I think it's
ridiculous but people do like the big
conspiracy theories done they especially
in times of panic cause people are
desperate for information they don't
trust a lot of people they don't trust
Boris Johnson they're telling the things
and I understand that I don't like Boris
Johnson either where I think Boris
Johnson has actually done quite well so
far in this is he's not said very much
at all he's especially pointed at the
scientist either side of him and as he
said right you answer those questions so
when he of the press converses with him
the chief scientific adviser for chief
medical officer who are both brilliant
chief medical officer Chris witty his
background as a fix diseases he's the
perfect man for the situation right now
and by Jenna's press conferences you
kind of see Boris answering questions on
a subject he knows nothing about nor
should he he's a politician who's kind
of used to handling questions about
whether pretty but he'll bullied people
in kind of near the ministry or whatever
he can handle less questions that's what
he's designed to do to ask the ones and
pressors on public health and
epidemiology he got my suit seen
panicking slightly when every speaking
about it but he does at least refer to
people either side of it which is good
we need to hear from those people but
obviously when it's still framed as the
government is telling us to stay indoors
and not go to the pub and so with a lot
of distrust about that and conspiracy
theories crop up so a someone I know
email me the other day I've had so many
inquires some people I've not spoken to
in years
I think remember me I've got a question
for you yeah one of the questions I had
was um there's a conspiracy theory going
around if you blast yourself in the face
of the hairdryer heat would kill the
virus that sounds brilliant
yep just as a layman can I have a theory
that the temperature you would need to
do that would be so hot you would burn
your face off
well I suspect there might be secondary
consequences before you got as far as a
virus we haven't researched we haven't
done a clinical trial on blasting
yourself in the face of the hairdryer so
we haven't tested this we can't sort of
say we can say no that's nonsense but
then if somebody says prove it we can't
print we can say look it's nonsense you
also have to go and take that theory
further and say write all the world's
infected use experts all of them none of
them reckon you can cure it by blossom
blasting yourself in the face with a
hair dryer but do you like crackpot
conspiracy theories person over there
you reckon you can so that the video I
got sent of it was by someone who just
happen to have a few books to sell but
someone who is I can't buy their name
otherwise I would have said it but they
wrote a book called something like cure
the common cold it's quite an old book
so whoever that person is they're not a
doctor they're not a medical researcher
they're no background effects diseases
but they do think you can cure corona
BrussPup glossing some of the place of a
hairdryer and by the way here's a few
books I've written in the past and so
again the conspiracy theories rock up
with their things to sell and a a theory
is it it doesn't have to be a cure and
that's clearly so silly it doesn't have
to be an accurate theory it just has to
catch people's attention and be
circulated for it to kind of achieve its
goal and there's just so much of that
out there there's a lot of scam
potential in times of scariness
something that I'm one thing I'm
concerned about with this kind of
community spirit that's building which
is great there'll be a lot of very
well-meaning actions that will have
consequences that no one had really
thought of and that Polly will include a
few unscrupulous types doing kind of you
know supermarket runs or old people
whilst nicking a few of their valuables
while their backs turn there will be a
bit of that happening you can just
guarantee it so those secondary
consequences of it are also important
and we need to try to we have to work
out as we go along
how much kind of
community action groups how much good
will come out to then compared to how
much negative will come out of then
hopefully be kind of a net positive but
we do think a little bit about again the
vulnerable people in society who we are
trying to help and to a few a very small
number of unscrupulous types will try to
very much not help well the law of
unintended consequences is so important
here because you were talking earlier
about shutting schools you get these
people you know Piers Morgan and others
screaming on Twitter oh you got to do
this you got to do that and you know the
there's so many unintended consequences
to many of these issues I mean you know
shutting down schools the point you made
is nurses doctors have children if they
have to stay at home with the children
they can't work also children then end
up with grandparents potentially
spreading the virus to vulnerable people
so although teachers mental health moves
skyrocket not being around children so
it's I mean we've got to be sensible
about this and the other point of course
is you start shutting things down that
has a huge economic impact the economy
tanks that kills people too you know so
there's got to be a balanced response to
this we can't just shut everything down
and and just focus on that alone can we
no so the economic consequences will be
huge of this and the social consequences
some of which we just touched on but
again elderly people not being visited
by the relatives anymore or not as much
as they were that's a problem for them
because they rely on that kind of social
contact to kind of enjoy their day go
get respirating
that's ironically what a friend of mine
has done he's actually taken a
respirator to go and see his parents
respirator yeah just a mask
no no respirator but can you console'
these people who are looking at their
elderly relatives and think oh they're
gonna die and you know all the rest of
it is that hyperbole or should we
prepare ourselves for the fact that
actually these people we've had in our
lives for so long our grandparents or
great uncles they might not be around
for one we're gonna see excess death in
the elderly from this so some people are
going to lose relatives or they
otherwise wouldn't have lost if this
pandemic hadn't occurred and
make it slightly cheerier the death
rates in the area 70s is kind of a
depending on how old the art kind of
various kind of five ten twenty percent
sort another so I see most people aren't
dying of it but I've seen many people
still are dying I mean I'm an
epidemiologist I look at numbers on a
spreadsheet quite a lot it was kind of
its depersonalized is just a mortality
rate but then if I kind of think back to
my own family I think about my elderly
relatives I've got one relative is over
ninety I'm thinking if she gets it big
problems potentially in terms of her
health and she's in relatively good
health her someone in their nineties
very systemic and a cheerful so they're
kind of withdrawal of social contact for
her in particular because she is a very
sociable person still he's a tricky
thing and I don't quite know how to
handle it for the best to be honest and
in the same way that I do worry if she
and other older relatives particularly
those you've got existing comorbidities
as we've discussed if they get it again
it's more likely to be serious so I can
number crunch during the day and then at
home I can't come at night and I do
worry I think about these things so I
don't know what the answer is and
touching and going to the situation and
in it in Italy is that why the situation
in Italy is so bad because they have a
very high percentage I think some like
twenty three percent of people age 60 or
over or is there something very specific
happening in Italy because at the moment
people are going look what's happening
in Italy this is going to be happening
here so we probably think that are least
in numbers of cases they're kind of
peaks and curves on the graph so we'll
follow something similar to Italy we are
a few bits behind so that's an advantage
so we can kind of watch what other
countries are doing and plan a little
bit accordingly so I think our early
case detection and contact tracing which
is basically when you find out a case
you kind of us who have you met who have
been in room with that sort of thing
that did slow the progress of the virus
in this country which has been very
helpful to buy us time just to work out
a bit better what to do the high
mortality rate in Italy I don't actually
quite know precisely why it's much
higher there a lot higher than in the
main countries I think that demographic
profile of Italy and England is not too
different I think they do have more
older people as a report on their
population than we do but I don't quite
know precisely why it started probably
as a range of factors that each
contribute a bit it might be that the
more older people it might be that the
health services weren't quite so
prepared as us in the UK I don't know if
that's true yup just my pathi sizing it
might be true there are some more
kissing there's a bit more they're more
tactile more affectionate people and
then families are closing it together in
different generations yeah so I mean
there's all really valid point and
actually the behavioral science of this
is firstly tricky secondly I think
massively underrated people like me who
win number crunchers we kind of look at
the numbers and then as the models who
come along to predict numbers throwing
in the behavioral side of things is so
important it's why you can't obviously
say italy or somewhere else to do
lockdowns why aren't we doing that here
it might be we should be doing that here
but we know from previous studies in
times of example during the 2009 swine
flu pandemic that there were analyses
done looking at the behavioral factors
across different countries and we know
that people in difficult respond in
different ways there's different levels
of compliance when it comes to washing
your hands people wash their hands in a
sentimental way but when it came to
restricting your contact patterns your
social distancing that was massively
variable across countries so again it
comes like Italy which is very very like
saving a lot of kissing or hugging lots
of intergenerational living without the
right phrase those are different factors
that will apply into modeling in Italy
that isn't so relevant here the waiting
should be a bit different so I'm always
a little bit cautious of saying the
government doing the wrong thing
particular when it it's clearly backed
by some of the leading scientists
they're seeing data that we haven't seen
I think we should see it there should be
more transparency about what evidence
they using to make decisions but as I
speak we haven't seen it they have
they've got an idea of what the evidence
says and of the local context so we can
learn lessons from Italy but we
shouldn't necessarily replicate Italy
because it's not the same situation here
we're all at different stages of the
outbreak as well so there will be
different interventions at different
times that's fair enough I think
and those London is fair to say that it
seems to be ahead of the curve if you
will why is that just if you could break
that down as to what is it the fact that
people are going on the tube a lot is it
buses what is it about being in London
or is it the fact that a lot of people
rent and lift
I'm it's a high density population which
is one key factor in rural areas
population densities much lower and the
fact that in London you are often
cramming more people into a small space
for example public transport public
transport is an interesting one we know
that international travel is a big
conduit for spread of effects diseases
that's kind of fairly obvious in a way
but we also have the evidence to prove
it because we can trap people we know
who gets on and off a plane we can track
where they go if it become a case in the
new country then you see exactly where
it's come from with buses and trains
you've no idea who's on the train so you
don't quite know you can kind of do some
concentration you can say blows on the
Piccadilly allow for 20 minutes this
morning but you're in a crammed space
for a fairly short period of time and
you also don't quite know if you pick up
a virus you've done lots of there's been
lots of other contacts during the day as
well so there's lots of opportunities
for contacts in London that you don't
have in a rural area for example but
it's also hard to pin down where you
picked up your infection from it could
be any one of those contacts who could
be the door handlers he left the Train
could be an on the train it could be in
the office it could have been in the pub
in the evening and making him on the
pint glass you touch that someone else
had you beforehand that hadn't been
proper clean all those sorts of things
so it makes the epidemiology of things
so fascinating but often hard to
disentangle but the higher population
densities is the big one and that makes
a lot of sense and that kind of leads me
into the question that I wanted to ask
is in the world that we live in now the
globalised interconnected everyone
traveling everywhere world is this gonna
keep happening with all kinds of
different things because we've seen it
you know you mentioned SARS and Mars
those didn't explode to the level that
this is likely to go to but are we gonna
you know continue to see this kind of
thing happening it's easier now for
outbreaks to happen for easier for
pandemic seven pandemics just don't
happen very often but we know that
always will be in next time so certainly
when this is said and done whenever that
be we need to learn lessons and properly
prepare globally
there's health systems in the poorer
parts of the world that if they do get a
lot of pandemic cases in their country
they're not gonna be able to cope the
bola decimated parts of West Africa that
they're not recovered from now so
globalization includes a spread of
infectious diseases but also in
sub-saharan Africa wherever you go
there's a can of coke these things which
then sort of leads to flat tooth decay
and obesity and cardiovascular disease
so even non-infectious diseases do
spread because of globalization and
increase connectivity obviously it's
great that we can travel to all parts of
the world and we've got to kind of the
internet that can connect everyone and
the downsides is that as sometimes as
infectious diseases Jim really decline
clearly not right now
with this one but on the whole infects
disease in most parts of what are going
down we're seeing non communicable
diseases like diabetes hypertension
cancer go up as in part also because
there's increasingly aging populations
so whereas in the poorer parts of Africa
let's say their life expectancy even
1020 years ago might have been 40 now it
might be 60 or so so those age-related
conditions kick in plus also the fact
that you might see a fast-food branch or
a can of coke almost anywhere in
different parts of the world so it
brings new health challenges to everyone
including effects diseases and including
things that have pandemic potential well
one of the things also shows isn't it
that we are as weak as our weakest link
in a sense as a global society of people
so if there's a wet market in China
where you've got these different animals
or you know bleeding all over each
others they're being slaughtered on
whatever you can close interaction with
humans we can't just like be arquette
that's know nothing to do with us
because that then leads to what we're
having now which is thousands of people
dying all over the world you know so
occasion there'll be that perfect storm
where the animal is slaughtered that
happens if infected in the context
another animal which then absorbs the
infection in itself it then meets the
human meets the human and humans able to
spread it and and then it kind of grows
exponentially it kind of needs a lot of
factors to come together but we've seen
that it is possible that kind of
mechanism does
work and sometimes works frightening ly
well with those food markets I did see
one newspaper I was going a few weeks
back saying that China had now banned
them I didn't see any follow up on that
and I didn't six didn't see that claim
more widely so don't know if that's the
case but it's certainly that Chinese
will need to look very closely at those
food markets and try and work out do
they need to be eating all these random
animals some of them are endangered I
think pangolins are putting endangered
probably I'm China yeah and but it's not
many of them are in the world so whether
that kind of importation of sort of fun
and funky animals needs to happen anyway
but there's I mean food markets are kind
of embedded in Chinese culture so it's
hard just to say to someone you're not
doing that anymore but also they have a
huge population and lots of master feed
that they're doing everything they can
to try and feed them yeah indeed whether
I then little accent pangolins might be
feeding many people until I tell you the
point that I was he they need to feed
their populations and they have
different diets to us and that's not to
be fair enough but we saw I can expect
them to behave ural side of things can
you shut down these these food markets
without much of consequence if the
Chinese government says in the
population we're doing it actually well
you probably can in other cultures it's
harder so with here's an example from
bird flu 2005 well they're about there
was a lot of concern it would get into
Africa and spread there with such poor
health systems that's a really big
problem in I think it was Nigeria there
were some cases in chickens which was
kind of that host of bird flu Schieber
flu was around today affects a few
people in Southeast Asia infected birds
a lot
some birds are fine it can fly around
and they mean those are probably them in
fact other birds who who suffer so it
still happens but a few chickens in a
Nigerian village got infected and the
kind of the minister came along and said
we'll take those thank you very much and
only way out they said will will will
give me compensation that's no good to
the village because that's their food
and a few days right there
so the Millers followed them at a
discreet distance the ministry people
basically went a few miles on the road
and buried them the Willys waited till
they'd gone and then dug them up in at
them so clearly public health wise you
should be doing that but these are
people who have one sort of
that's their chickens and they've been
promised money but they don't trust the
government and they may well not get it
therefore you see well they've done it
but and we saw with the bola as well
that a lot of the problems are kind of
with the bodily fluids so if you're
touching a dead body which happens a lot
in Africa you can listen to kind of part
of their burial process it's very
intimate it's not like in the UK where
they're in a boxing don't see them you
do have the bodies open you touch them a
lot and there was spread of Ebola quite
significantly from touching dead bodies
and with a boat around there were more
dead bodies attached so it was a problem
and we in the kind of Western world the
global North s is often the phrase now
handle it quite badly by basically
running to Africa saying stop that and
the population said okay these are our
embedded cultures what do you know about
us my dad's just died leave me alone
again you understand that kind of
response so again I'll come back to the
point I think social science and
anthropology and behavioral sciences
it's so underrated we do take their
mickey out of me this lipstick leave us
a number crunchers we looked down on the
social sources and we so shouldn't
because they are probably more valuable
than us I think in these kind of average
situations and do you think if it gets
into France and South America like you
said or parts of Africa where the you
know the health system isn't what it
should be
and you know the networks aren't strong
enough that it could decimate a
population no me there are already some
cases in for example in Africa it's
quite a few in Egypt but other Kay other
countries are any reporting anyway a few
very low numbers of cases there will
probably a lot more than what they've
got and the problem is I'm not I do
research in Ghana in West Africa and
also started links with colleagues and
toga which borders guy I was in both
countries in just a few weeks ago and
you see their health services and health
systems and there's no spare capacity
the NHS has a limited amount of capacity
that will be overwhelmed at some point
in the coming months it will be we just
know it will in Africa most countries
have no capacity at all so there is a
potential that it could get very very
scary for their populations with if
there are vast numbers of cases there
well hold on you say the NHS will be
overwhelmed we know that isn't the whole
part of the government's strategy
to flatten the peak so that we never get
to that point are you saying it's
inevitable they will be overwhelmed I
mean all the evidence we have including
the recent modeling papers that came out
of Imperial College says yes the editors
will be over them at some point
and the chief medical officer has said
that in his press conferences as well so
the kind of these interventions to try
to reduce these big Peaks the peak is
still going to go above NHS capacity so
we will what you're saying is within
weeks or maybe months we will be in the
position where it's a lien doctors are
now where they're having to basically
try as who do they give life-saving
support I mean almost certainly yeah and
that that's pretty clear that we can't
expect that hopefully it won't happen
but that is what we expect to happen in
two or three months time well I think
this is really important because when we
talk about people not complying with the
government's advice and all this kind of
thing that's what we're talking about
right that that's the end product of
that behavior yeah so social distancing
is a key part of this and it's something
that we all have to do we all contribute
too so if there is low compliance with
these kind of measures that we put in
place and then the NHS is even more
overwhelmed than it could have been
actually that's our fault
to some extent so before we wrap up with
the interview then just tell us wash our
hands right but this virus is is mainly
spread through just breathing the same
air as other people isn't it so is it's
a respira to one so it kind of goes out
and aerosols but you touch services and
so on where the virus is so washing your
hands it's so unsexy and dull but it's
so important anyway
oh we should be washing our hands
thoroughly many times a day let me ask
the question in different way if you had
it now would we get it potentially you
would be defined you too and behind the
camera there you'd be defined as
contacts of mind so a contact was
defined as something like within 2
meters for 15 minutes or more so if you
sat the restaurant next to someone new 2
meters away then that's a contact we've
been sat in that kind of proximity so
they would send you there be reasonable
chance that you would have it so
actually if I have got it now I develop
symptoms tomorrow I'm probably
infectious now oh yeah
you've been infectious for days if you
if you had symptoms tomorrow right
probably an infectious one or two days I
reckon the amount that you can spread
the virus before you show symptoms most
respiratory infections is a day or two
beforehand it's not usually a long
period of time right the the incubation
period from when you get exposed to when
you show symptoms that's usually most of
there's about five days so I think the
infectious period which is the timing
you can spread the virus before you show
symptoms it's a slightly different
definition that's probably one to two
days can I just say I'm offended I am
that you've referred to him as my
contact anyway there we go but there's
one question I really want to dig down
on which was that you said the NHS will
be overwhelmed and I think people are
not really taking on board what that
means can you explain in clearer detail
what does it mean when the NHS health
system is overwhelmed what does that
look like in real world figures data
situations I can't provide the figures
or the data on it cuz it's kind of a
hypothetical probably will happen
scenario but what it means is there
won't be enough AIDS in hospital there
might be enough doctors and nurses and
someone to treat you there won't be
enough bits of equipment like
respirators and ventilation we've heard
a lot about that over the last few weeks
and so I mean like I say with doctors in
Italy them and triage their patients to
try to work out who to treat who to give
the ventilators to at the moment if
someone needs a ventilator they can have
it on the hull because there's enough
capacity in the health service when we
get overwhelmed there won't be enough
ventilators so it could get very very
tricky at that point so again it's down
to all of us to lessen the impact of
that because that could be our
grandmother or mother or a relative or
someone that's sat in that hospital bed
who hasn't got the equipment they need
because in part we weren't very good
with our social distancing compliance so
that effectively means that the doctor
looks at two patients they've got a
respirator and they go well this one's
over 75 this one 65 this one stands 20%
chance more of making it I'm gonna give
the respirator to them and unfortunately
that patient is left to their own
devices almost I mean there'll be
they'll be treated as best they can yeah
if you've not got enough bits of
equipment to go around then you do have
to work at who to give it to I'm going
to kind of go back to Ghana you'll want
to speaking to people
in the hospitals there and they say
we've got loads of children with
pneumonia here I've got a very limited
amount of capacity to test what bug
they've got I've got maybe two tubes a
day to two blood tests I can take a day
to kind of work out what's wrong with
your children there's 50 of them in a
hospital which two am i picking that's
what happens in Ghana and country every
single day to a lesser extent but still
important extent here our medics are
gonna be facing stove sort of questions
it's not gonna be fun and it doesn't
sound like fun at all which is why we
wanted to talk to you because I think is
important that this information gets out
there as much as we can help with that
but thank you very much for taking the
time and having us in your home and not
infecting us hopefully will come in a
few days time yeah compare notes we'll
find out if we're still there live in a
few days but the last we only have one
more question for you and the last
question we always ask is and in this
case in this particular context what is
the one thing that no one is talking
about that we ought to be talking about
you know I'm gonna say the word scabies
you weren't expecting that were you no
no now scabies is one of my most
fascinating bugs I do research on
including in Ghana it's a mite doesn't
like a head lice that is literally
everywhere it causes itchiness rashes
it's really unpleasant it doesn't kill
many people she send you a wind of her
much what scabies and last few weeks
because everyone's talking about that
does kill people which is fair enough
but scabies is kind of these one of them
under thought about conditions that is
right for around the world we have it we
did a study in the UK looking Scabbers
in care homes where there's plenty of it
and it infects people with dementia more
than people without dementia so in fact
the most vulnerable people and so on and
so forth there's about 400 million cases
or so have scabies every single year
around the world
it's vast it's unpleasant it's hard to
get rid of its badly diagnosed there's a
lot of stigma attached to it we should
talk more about scabies when we suffer
macarena must do that first but then
secondary scabies and who thought EPDM
I'll just won't sexy Mike thank you so
much for taking the time it's great
chatting with you and are you on social
media by the way you sharing information
putting anything out there for people to
follow spreading fight news I'm on
Twitter Michael G head is my twitter
handle I'm not really on many other
social media so Twitter's probably not
to talk sure not yet maybe maybe a bit
more time in any kind of a lockdown
situation maybe our border do a few
videos but for now that's where I am so
go follow Michael and we'll see you very
soon if we're all still here with
another brilliant episode see you next
week guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel click
the bell button next to subscribe button
so you get notified when a video comes
out and follow us on all the social
media at trigger pod and also leave us a
nice review on iTunes and spread the
word